par exemple dont on compare les demis
voilà on se dise est stop ou encore est
ce que le défilé en maillot de bain par
exemple vous aujourd'hui vous trouvez ça
bien ou faudra le supprimer je sais pas
en fait soyons de beauté bon moi je sais
qu'à l'heure actuelle on me demanderait
de défiler en maillot de bain je ne
ferai plus culture y est plus ensuite ma
tante mon choix mais ça reste un
concours de beauté donc après est-ce
qu'il faut alors supprimer le défilé
victoria's secret est est-ce qu'il faut
défiler il faut arrêter les et mon
shooting en maillot de bain ou en double
alors j'étais un petit peu dur je dis
qu'effectivement c'est voilà ces défilés
et puis derrière allait faire un peu
d'aidé fois au bout d'un an ça sarr dont
j'étais un petit peu dur mais c'est
parce que au contraire je j'ai pas envie
qu'on comprenne ça des femmes et qu'on
voit ça des femmes est ce qu a eu un
moment où vous avez vous vous êtes senti
humilié ou est ce qu'il ya un moment que
vous n'avez voilà que vous avez vécue de
manière difficile pendant cette année
oui effectivement il ya eu un moment qui
restera gravé dans ma mémoire c'est
aller à l'élection de miss univers en
fait
il y avait une répétition et à l'époque
c'était donald trump qui était donc
président de miss de miss univers
n'était pas président des états unis et
du coup il est passé devant toutes les
filles
ouais et ils nous regardaient de la tête
aux pieds et disait nice tous ici un
permet d'annoncer les dans la bonne
santé alors juste victime en donc stop
aussi après il y aura quelques encore
mais stop myriam pardon catherine
pourquoi alors pardon je vais hamlin
dans une note un peu discordante il en
faut toujours une pour ce genre de débat
moi je suis farouchement contre
exactement ce pour que ce que vous dite
rachel c'est une foire à l'exhibition
féminine
on n'est jugé que sur son physique et
parallèlement une violence faite aux
femmes pourquoi parce que il ya ça se
déchaîne sur les réseaux sociaux pendant
qu'elle défile sur leur supposée niveau
intellectuel que l'on suppose un peu
faible et signe une extrême violence
seulement voilà il rappelez-vous il
enfin rappelez vous on n'était pas la
face vous n'étiez pas né moi oui mes
côtés à la fois une des vieilles lunes
et même siècle du 19e siècle pardon mon
exil mais juste des noirs qu'on appelait
les bons sauvages pour les montrer à la
fin on les regarder comme ça
tous parlaient même immersion qui
étaient ceux qui étaient faites à ces
gens là et que l'on fait subir aux
femmes aujourd'hui est super drôle
altrad importante encore magali
attendent autant des jeunes mais les
hommes non pas les difficultés qu'ont
les femmes écrit catherine savoir la vie
de rachel mais juste parce que rachel là
où je rejoins catherine je pose juste
une question et vous avez vous pourrez
répondre c'est non seulement on
s'attache à montrer que vous êtes belle
mais en plus de ça à montrer que vous
êtes idiote parce que vous pose des
questions auxquelles personne ne sait
répondre
donc c'est soit belle et en plus tu es
toi après c'est le stress etc sont des
jeunes filles qui ne sont ce qu'ils ne
se sont jamais exprimés comme ça devant
des caméras et des millions de
téléspectateurs c'est pas et c'est pas
évident mais elles ont toutes un
parcours voit la belle uma la puce vous
m'avez dit rachel à la pub pardon
c'était pas un secret je pense vous avez
dit ce que je regrette le plus dans ce
concours c'est qu'on ne s'intéresse pas
oui en fait j'aimerais je trouve que
cela serait bien en fait qu'on suive un
peu les nice dans leur passion par
exemple une pièce de théâtre qu'on
puisse la découvrir une autre que soi un
mix d'être une marianne finalement elle
a eu il savait bien que pendant
l'émission c'est lui que les gens qui
regardent c'est le mythe de la jolie
cruche et horrible je suivais mois après
je tiens à signaler que je trouve un cas
moi mon époque où c'était encore
geneviève de fontenay et endemol bon oui
c'est encore ensemble vous et rêver les
petites filles plus banal je ne sais pas
si c'est encore bel et bien sûr que oui
c'est pareil mais en attendant il faut
pas oublier que ont fait rêver des
petites filles moi je sais que l'on m'a
il ya une petite fille a reçu oui oui
petit garçon mais moi je me sens bien au
jeu des dédicaces une maman qui me voir
à qui a dit merci
ce grâce à vous ma fille est sortie de
l'anorexie parce que j'ai été une des
miss avec des formes j'ai été un peu
critiqué pour ça justement mais elle m'a
dit ben voilà elle vous a vu à la ville
vous aviez des formes et que ce n'était
pas nécessaire de se faire vomir pour
être jolie et j'aimerais en tout cas
qu'un jour une miss france sera élue et
quelques allées beaucoup plus de fort ah
ça oui mais je vais me présenter l'année
prochaine
maison de retraite 2020 daniel marcotte
sera tournus koga twilight ottomane à la
parole à daniel qui est elle veut le
défilé avec tout le respect que je vous
dois ce que vous dites ou les bras
serrés aux moines à exactement ce que
vous dites là c'est le son ce mot-clé
joli crochet tout ça c'est le sentiment
de ses du parisianisme c'est qu'il
regardera supérieur et les 12 millions
de gens risquent d'abord vous connaissez
beaucoup d'émissions de télévision et
d'événements qui réunisse deux millions
de personnes à part les coupes du monde
huit
et sur les 12 millions de personnes il
ya une petite frange qui se moque mais
il ya la vraie france celle des filles
de il ya un rendez vous chez les filles
de français moyens y avait chez là dans
les années 60 c'est des petites filles
de français moyen qui tout d'un coup une
vie un jour à nous non on a vraiment des
spectateurs en légitime cette future à
l'exhibition servi aux hommes pendant
des années sa nage et les personnes mais
non elle est non catherine catherine
katrina l'attend vaio dans l'ordre
sébastien qui est même et guillaume con
ce que tu fais c'est du féminisme
exacerbé démagogie nos mythes ou doit
pas devenir une dictature
donc c'est un concours de beauté ça doit
rester un concours de beauté si
maintenant le ce concours de beauté on
ne peut plus regarder les femmes qui
défilent ça sert à quoi oui sinon celle
de marianne ce que j'aime c'est la
marianne si oui alors guillaume qui est
pour et magali aussi qu' il faut le
prendre pour ce que c'est une tradition
c'est joli c'est me soucier un concours
de beauté donc évidemment qu'on veut les
voir en maillot
après la france et le monde sait que on
préfère voir des femmes en maillot que
des garçons en maillot de bain même les
femmes préfèrent voir comme le monde a
changé le monde a changé de sujet
aujourd'hui néron couvrons les statuts
du louvre en c'est top c'est le triste
fois récit si ces deux là
non mais vous voulez tout cacher je ne
veux pas second de la moselle sans mal
et que ça ça n'est pas bien méchant
c'est gentil c'est bien beau la business
pour tf1 et endemol quitte sa licence
le commandant mais un énorme business
l'argentine en couverture jeu
parce que on est obligé de le faire mais
il adore miss france
mais c'est une vraie vache à lait mois
on quand on quand on fait un magazine et
qu'on veut foot est une miss france on
nous demande une fortune alors qu'on va
pas forcément la demande et à d'autres à
d'autres journaux et c'est pas elle qui
touchent forcément l'argent
donc c'est un énorme business sur ses
fils à et je suis désolé c'est pas elle
qui est d'accord lyon mais quand on part
documentaire qu'on veut acheter des
images ça coûte très très cher ou
d'argent la miss franche comté et gong
en dise pas qu'on me dise moi je dis
vous êtes ont gagné de beaux cadeaux ou
quatre voitures des couronnes de ma
chambre je gagne toujours pas et un
appartement reviennent pas oui parce
qu'on gagne pas l'appartement on est
logique l'udc
vous vous souvenez vous et de pardon
vous ai parlé déjà non j'ai pas parlé
encore albert dont les je ne comprends
même pas qu'on puisse dire qu'on va
arrêter miss france parce que c'est
quelque chose d'anormal et de ben 10
minutes elles sont à le reste du temps
elles sont en robe du soir et elles sont
plutôt mise en valeur et c'est très
bizarre de dire que ça attaque les
femmes et c'est grâce à un propos qui
complètement d'ailleurs fallu qu elles
sont toutes sont toutes les études
mènera elles ont toutes été dans les
médecins comment peut il me paraît
normal et m toutefois la mission plus
qu'à quelques semaines dans cette
émission on a fait une émission et
rachète peut en parler parce que perdre
on va dire aussi rachel lorsqu'elle a
été élue miss ensuite bal a eu un enfant
à marie et ensuite elle était au smig
pendant un petit moment
c'était très compliqué mais on avait
fait tout un sujet la thur arraché c'est
là dessus que je vous entendre il ya
quelques semaines en effet un sujet
qu'est ce qu'on a comme comme à venir
après les mises comment les a élus en
disant tu es belle m'étais idiote et
bien après plus personne n'en veut et ça
on n'a pas des réalités à moi c'est
difficile quand même parce qu'après on
ne veut de vous que la beauté c'est pas
une question de mois c'est bon c'est mon
parcours personnel c'est parce que voilà
j'ai connu une rupture et j'ai du mal à
rebondir par la suite et et parce que
j'ai aussi je me suis arrêté de
travailler pour élever mon enfant
enfin une miss au smic s'étonnant que
même quand on n'est pas parce qu'on
passe à l'as mâcon et milliardaire les
gens arrêtent de croire ça donc on a les
mêmes soucis à tout le monde
on rencontre voilà des des déceptions
amoureuses et voilà il faut rebondir moi
j'ai voulu retravailler ensuite quand
mon fils est entré à l'école j'ai repris
des études parce que j'estime et
justement j'ai pas pu reprendre mes
études après miss france parce que ben
voilà j'étais un peu aveuglé par toutes
ces premières
donc après avoir digéré
tout ça j'ai repris des études j'étais
en alternance et oui j'ai touché le smic
pendant un an avant d'être embauché
maintenant vous êtes animatrice télé sur
une gilles galud des noms mais du coup
je cumule pas mal de petits travail de
petits travaux pardon à côté pour
essayer de 2 voilà deux et vous sortez
avec un gma pas mal plus chaud l'heure
et ça ça me ferait très bien ça rapporte
rien mais bon un jour vous fait la passe
décisive je suis là je suis là je réagis
très généreuse moitié pour le foot y'a
les adore il est très très beau on n'est
pas passé loin d'une proposition à 3,20
jamais j'arrive il va bien on vous a
demandé sur twitter dans votre avis sur
les miss pardon il faut qu'on avance un
petit bout on a plein de sujets le conte
koné s'est pour une fois c'est la
première fois que les gens sont d'accord
avec moi ça me touche quand même